before we begin since this is a BBC
owned property I feel the need to point
out that the news armor the BBC has a
continuing issue with transphobic
leanings in its news coverage you can
find in a pinned comment below various
videos from both myself and other
YouTubers covering this issue and while
I understand that the Doctor Who
creative team is not responsible for
this I will continue to point this out
for as long as it remains a consistent
issue thank you
so
tell me about your journey
foreign
[Music]
there's so much to love about Doctor Who
the imagination on display the fact that
it can go anywhere anywhere
but the characters I think are what
bring most of us back over and over
again the doctor themselves obviously
but the companions recurring villains
even
but which characters have had the best
Journeys
who's had the best character Arc
well it's it's the 12th doctor it's
Peter Capaldi and he will not be
eligible for this list because I
literally already did an entire video
explaining why I think that is an
amazing Arc and why it means so much to
me personally so he's being excluded
because otherwise if you know my
material at all it's too dang obvious
so here we go I'm going to be giving you
what I think are the best character arcs
of modern era Doctor Who I considered
adding classic into this but even some
of the ones who I considered for it I
haven't seen enough of all their stuff
to really be able to fully chart out the
arc even though I can think of a few who
probably would make the list if I do
this again down the line after I've
taken in some more classic than I have
Ace but
this is going to be a list of seven
which is a weird number I know the the
problem was I had too many that I wanted
to talk about to limit it to five but I
didn't have enough that I thought were
truly worth talking about to make it to
10. because some characters have
perfectly serviceable arcs but are kind
of unremarkable some characters don't
really seem to have much in a way of an
arc and that isn't even a knock on the
character because sometimes if you
characterize somebody the right way and
you make them fun and interesting they
don't have to go through a massive
journey and change to still be really
compelling so this is not a ranking of
the characters in and of themselves and
this is a completely separate notion
from who I think is the best companion
or whatever so this is just talking
about the journeys they went on their
arcs so let's start at the bottom of
this particular list and keep in mind
even the ones at the bottom are ones I
thought were worth talking about so
we'll start there we'll work our way up
let us begin then with number seven
Martha Jones
Martha goes to a really good journey
for multiple reasons on multiple levels
because it is a journey of her gaining
more confidence in herself she's
incredibly intelligent that's
demonstrated right from her very first
episode
what was your name Martha you might die
we might not
good but she's also a student she knows
she has a lot to learn and so a lot of
her journey over the course of series
three is learning to have the confidence
in what she does know bones of the hand
carpal bones proximal row scaphoid
lunate triquetra pisiform distal Road
trapezium trapezoid capitate hammock we
read that in a book yes to pass my exams
and getting to have that strength within
herself to make a choice because she
knows this is the right thing she's got
a stubborn streak and we see that early
on but this is part of why she chooses
to leave the Tardis at the point and in
the way that she does
is me
getting help
[Music]
she knows her value
by the end of Series 3 she's been
through enough and she has done enough
she has personally helped save the world
she knows her value
and she knows that she's not going to
get from the doctor
what she wants and that makes this an
inequitable situation and she can't keep
doing it and good for her and if you're
wondering why she's at the bottom it's
because uh certain aspects of this are
undermined by her appearances after
Series 3 such as working with unit the
the way she does is that what you did
too turned into a soldier that one's not
too bad but then at the very end showing
her just running around with a gun
paired off with Mickey and this is low
place for a married woman
you shouldn't have married me what what
was that what even was that
it doesn't completely undermine her Arc
and it's not even inherently belittling
but like it's such a weird note to end
her on when she had such a strong
departure from the Tardis and a decent
enough appearance after that but come on
number six
Mickey Smith wow speak of the devil and
uh we will not be addressing any of the
issues around Noel Clark as a figure or
as a person or any of the stuff that has
gone on in the last few years not
dealing with it we are just talking
about the character of Mickey who
somewhat similarly to Martha needs to
understand his worth his value and build
confidence because he had spent a chunk
of his life thinking he really just
wasn't going to amount to much and he
was just there to have a laugh with rose
and maybe for him that would even have
been enough
but there's more than that out there
and over his time
relatively brief time actually over the
course of uh series one and into series
two traveling in the Tardis well he
learns what he's worth he learns what
matters to him
and he learns to go for those things
he learned to let go of rose
but embrace meeting his grandmother
again
because he felt like he'd lost that time
and he had the chance to embrace it once
more
and then having gotten that and had that
time
to make a stand do the right thing
help save the world multiple times
he's slightly above Martha because the
last note we get him on honestly makes a
hell of a lot more sense for him him
running around you know with a gun uh
defending the Earth taking on you know
aliens or what it makes way more sense
than Martha Martha I can definitely buy
would always care about what's going on
with aliens but the fact that you know
she's a doctor she's a Healer she has
expressed to care about people but
she's decided to go about that by just
shooting things
if it was ever going to work for her we
needed more information about how she
got there Mickey it's more natural and
makes more sense
number five
Amy Pond
whereas the other characters that I've
talked about up to this point a big part
of their Journey was coming to know
their own worth and to basically stand
up for their own place
uh Amy kind of had to do the opposite
Amy I am going to need my car first in a
bit now go and have coffee right
Amy when she starts out has a bit of an
inflated sense of self-worth in terms of
just being used to getting what she
wants and there's a fantastic Dynamic
right off the bat between her and the
doctor because he's let her down in the
past and he's one of the major people in
her life to do that
but she is a pretty selfish person
initially she's here for the fun
that's why she is willing to try and
jump the doctor's bones even when she's
about to marry Rory
it's you it's all about you everything
it's about you
because
she wants what she wants
and at first she is not really thinking
about whether or not that impacts
anybody other than her
but she doesn't stay that way
over the course of the seasons and with
encounters with people like Vincent or
with incidents like what happens with
the Flesh and the gangers and losing and
then regaining and then losing again and
regaining again Rory
Amy comes to understand that
she can't just go about gallivanting and
just trying to have nothing but fun
forever
she has to make a choice about what her
life is actually going to be and that
will mean closing off the possibilities
in some areas in order to have others
and that is her ultimate choice at the
very end she has a choice the doctor
or Rory
and she's willing to close the door on
the doctor
to have what she can't live without
and that's not a choice I think she
would have been able to make before
I think she would have been Paralyzed by
being put in a situation where she even
had to make that choice
she was sad to make it but she did
because of the journey she'd gone
through
number four
Rory Williams here we are coming back to
the character who learns his own value
but it's not just about learning his own
value it's about getting confidence in
the value that he he has to other people
so it's not just about what he's worth
it's about standing up
for what he knows he can give to other
people Amy in particular again to make
the comparison you look at how unsure of
himself how unsteady he is when he first
gets introduced at sorry series five
and then you see him in the Centurion
outfit
just strolling in where is my wife I
think when first introduced Rory might
have still done it but he wouldn't have
been able to do it with confidence he
wouldn't have been able to do it with
strength of conviction he wouldn't have
been able to do it with certainty
but he could by the time that happened
and
he
loves Amy and he's always loved Amy
but he also comes to understand that
he's not just there to love her and
nothing else he gives her more than just
affection and loyalty and he comes to
understand that over time as they come
to Value what they offer each other
and again ultimately to have that
decision to stay together
even if it means they can't travel
anymore
why did I put him slightly above Amy
I don't know I think I'm just slightly
more of a sucker for the person finds
confidence in themselves story uh then
person becomes slightly humbler both are
valid but you know personal preference I
could easily swap those two
number three
the Ninth Doctor
now this is one of a couple of different
things depending on how you want to view
it if you want to view it strictly by
the chronological airing of episodes
what we start out with is someone in
pain who uh has gone through a
tremendous loss and who does not want to
put himself in a position where he's
going to lose anything again
until gradually opening up
to the point that he is when faced with
almost the same decision he made just
before the start of series one
makes the opposite choice because he's
not the same person coward
any day and the other way to look at it
if you want to take the bigger scope and
take the timeline slightly ahead of
where series 1 starts
well
then you have someone who made or at
least remembers having made
the worst decision of his existence
he did something horrible
and maybe he even has a little bit of a
death wish
he wants to still help people he wants
to keep being the doctor and he is
but he is traveling alone
he is throwing himself into situations
where
he could easily die
he doesn't seem especially panicked at
the idea when he might sometimes not a
lot and when he does more about the
circumstances than the fact itself I've
pushed boxes of the Boston Tea Party now
I'm gonna die in a dungeon
Cardiff but then he finds Rose
and they build that connection
and he refines his ability
to care not just about the universe
because he always cared about universe
but about himself he valued himself
probably the least of anybody
and he came to understand what he meant
to Rose because of what she did to try
and save him but he cared about her too
much to let her do that maybe that's
what he still would have done if the
whole bad wolf thing had happened
earlier in the series but I don't think
his exact motivation would have been the
same
I think there is a difference in why
he saves Rose and then regenerates at
the end of the series then if it had
happened at the beginning because if it
had happened at the beginning it would
have been almost just instinctive
someone's in trouble this is what I do
at the end it is a much more deliberate
choice
and it's a much more informed choice
because he's not running on autopilot
anymore
and that journey to see him get invested
again
that's great
number two
Missy
folks should have guessed that this was
going to be on here first of all Missy
is one of my favorite well currently my
favorite master
um but she is fun
dangerous in her own words
and she just seems to be tearing through
time doing whatever strikes her fancy
because it's fun but eventually the fun
isn't enough and she starts to long for
that connection
to the doctor now the master has sought
out the doctor before repeatedly and
initially she does seek him out to kind
of Torment him and mess with him
but then we get to series nine and she's
seeking him out because he thinks he's
dying and she's his friend
she's still very messy about it
but things are shifting
and then we get to series 10 and she
wants that friendship back
she has seen and been through and lost
enough
that she doesn't want the conquest the
chaos the fun isn't fun anymore and she
wants to try and get back what she once
had and Michelle Gomez does a really
good job at selling that maybe just
maybe just this time if only this time
she can be the doctor's friend again
still be herself
but be his friend once more and I enjoy
that I like that trip
I like it a lot
but number one again if you are um
a regular this channel shouldn't be a
huge surprise
um especially with Capaldi out of the
rounding but
number one
Donna Noble
obviously uh there's more to her that we
are going to be seeing uh a little bit
down the line once we get to the the
specials with David Tennant but for
right now
it's not just that Donna goes through
major personality changes and growth
from how we first meet her loud abrasive
yelling annoying
[Music]
just stepping on everybody's toes
superficial to
someone who's deeply empathetic just
amazingly warm-hearted and building such
an incredible platonic friendship with
the doctor it's not just that Journey
it's the fact that which he first showed
up in the Runaway Bride I didn't like
her
I didn't like her at all even on
re-watch
I still don't like her in that but it's
the fact that she starts there
she starts out like that
and over time
sees people
and alien species and the universe in
jeopardy
and comes to realize how big everything
is but how much everyone in it still
matters
her journey of her empathy opening up
through experiences like fires upon pay
planet of the you'd and then the
eventual heartbreak
over things like Journey's End
where she has found a way to help
almost everybody
but she can't hold on to it
this isn't just about how gorgeously
tragic her departure is I really hope
that doesn't get undermined we'll see
but
it's the fact that she truly had become
the best that Humanity has to offer
and then it was taken from her
but before it was that journey to get
there it was believable
it was heartwarming
it was amazing
and that's why I think Donna Noble had
the best character Arc of modern era
Doctor Who
who do you think who did I leave out who
would you include from classic whatever
your thoughts might be drop something
down in the comments let's talk about it
patreon is what pays the bills around
here it gets you early access to these
videos up to a week in advance in fact
you get that perk at every tier of
support and there's other things that
you can get at other tiers as well but
don't worry too too much about it the
like share subscribe thing that helps me
out as well but uh don't worry about
that all that much either because what I
really want you to remember
is that wherever you are on your journey
and your Arc
you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
end of the video so I got a shout out my
top patrons Robin Moore Zubin with
Fuller to rock the thing that goes doing
in the anime Oliver B Angus bjornison
Melinda Walters kimudelki the oatha Boyd
catoria toyololi Becky Sparks for
nabilox the poodle Zach Tracy scrabot
angry Casper Tim price Adam r d l Taylor
gourlay and Brendan Larose
thanks for your support if you want to
hear me probably mispronounce your name
as well check out the rewards on the
patreon
what are you doing there
[Music]